JENNY BROWN: Today we're
talking about security
and sustainability.
I'm Jenny Brown and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Google Cloud has launched a
security solution, Web App
and API Protection, where
we're combining three products
to provide comprehensive
threat protection for your web
applications and APIs--
Google Cloud Armor, Apigee,
and reCAPTCHA Enterprise.
We've got an on-demand webinar,
a white paper, and a solution
page to help you
get started today.
Some of the most important
data at your company
isn't living in databases
but in documents.
And most business
processes begin, involve,
or end with a document.
Many organizations are
still manually entering data
and leaving heaps of value
on the table in terms
of better customer experiences.
The latest release of Document
AI platform, Lending DocAI,
and Procurement DocAI, built
on decades of AI innovation
at Google, bring powerful
and useful solutions
to these challenges.
Check out the blog to
learn more about what's
going on under the hood.
From efficient data centers
to purchasing renewable energy
at scale, Google is
dedicated to doing our part
to protect the
environment and planet.
Chrome OS provides sustainable
computing software and hardware
through our ecosystem of
partners and customers,
from energy efficiency
to responsible supply
chain and operations.
Check out the link for more.
We've launched an updated
version of our Google Cloud
Security Foundations Guide
and corresponding Terraform
Blueprint scripts.
In these resources we provide
opinionated step-by-step
guidance for creating
a secured landing zone
into which you can configure
and deploy your Google Cloud
workloads.
From key decision points
to areas of focus,
we provide the why behind
our recommendations,
but of course, you're
free to do your own thing.
Check them out in our
Best Practices Center.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.